welcome everybody to my introduction to
quadrupeds i think everyone who sees
quadrupeds probably thinks of boston
dynamics and spot and that's really no
different for me ever since i saw spot i
really just wanted to work with it
especially with the mentioned python api
and all that but
spot is something like seventy thousand
dollars if they even let you buy one to
begin with so how does somebody get into
this field and why what excites me most
about quadrupeds is the taking of your
programming to the physical world you
can physically see it and interact with
it and there's just something like
really neat about doing that i felt that
before with small like robot cars and
quadcopters but the options of what you
can actually do
with something like a robot car
they're pretty minimal mostly because
even the most benign surfaces or even
transitions between surfaces can thwart
a four-wheeled vehicle
now quadcopter drones are extremely
versatile
but the battery life is eight minutes or
so so
that makes using it a pain as well as
just r d a pain plus drones also
struggle with most payloads with
quadrupeds or robot dogs you can
navigate all kinds of different terrain
cross door transitions with no problems
go upstairs walk on gravel and so on
functionally quadrupeds can do
incredible things we know this to be
true with dogs cats and and so on the
quadrupeds that we have today are
technically capable of running at very
high speeds climbing and doing all sorts
of really awesome maneuvers but what
currently holds them back most often is
actually the software in the ai that
drives them because it's actually a
fairly challenging ai problem just to
walk around on four legs without falling
much less run or climb
so to me this seems like a really
interesting and cool problem to work on
but the question is how do you even get
started here the barrier to entry is
quite high if you want to buy your way
in and then i've also considered
building my own and this is definitely
something that i would still like to do
eventually but building your own is
really like a year or more of just like
r d and trial and error and i'd really
like to have some idea of where i'm
trying to go before i do that and still
yet my main interest is really in
building the software and less about
building the actual quadruped itself
while i was searching for options and
trying to learn more about building from
scratch i did find a channel called
mjbots where josh here has been
cataloging his multi-year long process
in building his quad a1 if you are
interested in building from scratch and
learning more about that definitely
check out his channel i'll put a link in
the description but if nothing else it
should show you how much effort is
required just to build the the hardware
and body of a quadruped another option
is there are stls and other build files
for spot micro and even other quadrupeds
on things like thingiverse which is a
great starting point if you want to
build one for yourself i'll also link to
that in the description if you're
interested but right at the perfect time
the luwoo team behind the exco mini
project on kickstarter reached out and
asked if i would be interested in
checking out their x go mini so that
wasn't obvious yes and that's what i
have here i tend to shy away from
promoting kickstarters because
especially from people i don't know
because you have no idea how that
kickstarter is going to pan out so
instead i will just say here this is
purely my thoughts on the thing that i
was sent all the same risks are
associated with kickstarter campaigns i
don't know the company or the people
behind this project so i'm just
happening to to use this and what i can
say is the unit that i did receive is
pretty awesome for what i am interested
in doing and again i'll put a link to
the this campaign as well in the
description
so right out of the box there is a phone
app that you can install and connect to
the x go mini and control it over
bluetooth within like 10 seconds there's
probably a bunch of small quadrupeds
like this where you can just kind of
control them but really it's just kind
of like a toy so in the phone app there
are some demo actions and tricks that
you can do they're kind of silly but
should also spark some ideas of what you
could program this bot to do one thing
for example is the range of motion of
each of the legs is surprisingly large
it can basically scratch its own back i
also suspect i could make this thing
climb up ledges at least of a few inches
maybe not full human stairs
but still some significant climbing
i think they probably didn't include any
climbing in the actions
because of the likelihood of failure and
falling
but that's definitely one of the things
i want to try i think it's pretty clear
that they tried to make this as stable
as possible
the version i was sent also has an ai
module on the front which has a camera
and then a computing and processing
board on the front so it does cool other
demos like face tracking and gesture
tracking and all that so it's actually
running deep learning models right there
on that board and again that's pretty
impressive to have included and again
just kind of like sparks like ideas
about things like maybe you could have
like human detection and then you could
actually follow the human around so
that's kind of interesting so what
excited me most about the exco mini
though for my personal introduction to
quads is that the
the quadruped is completely programmable
and it actually has multiple layers of
this programming at the core of all
these quadrupeds you've got all your
motors and these motors have a
controller even just to walk around you
need to address the movements of three
motors
per leg along with the imu or the
inertial measurement unit and this makes
again in my opinion building and
programming quadrupeds a pretty massive
undertaking so not only are you trying
to develop the the hardware and the
design of all the elements to be robust
and functional
just doing the a basic thing like
walking around without falling is
actually a fairly complex task but with
this quadruped they have a serial
protocol which kind of has everything
you could possibly want at least that's
functionally capable on this quad
essentially there are some basic status
things here but then there are these
three layers of control so at the
highest level layer you have this whole
body mode where really you're calling
for very high level commands like move
forward backward rotate along some
specific axis and and so on they also
have all of the kind of demo tricks that
the robot can do
in this mode so with whole body mode
you're using all of their algorithms for
gate and just like moving around
rather than addressing each of the 12
motors individually so imagine all
you're trying to do is navigate a
hallway or follow a human around or
something like that you would probably
just need to use whole body mode and you
can still program the quadruped but if
that's not enough for you you can get a
bit deeper and do single leg mode
here you're controlling the entire leg
by positioning the xyz coordinates of
just the feet so again rather than
attempting to move the three motors
individually just to move a leg in some
custom way you can just specify where
you want that foot to be and again the
algorithm can do it for you and in this
way you could also specify like if you
need that foot to move to that position
in a specific way
again you could specify those xyz
coordinates in some specific order to
get that to be the case so here you
might want to use single leg mode if
you're trying to get some custom action
so i think i could make this quadruped
climb things like like stairs not
full-size human stairs but maybe 3-4
inches or so
and if i wanted to do that this would
probably be the mode that i would be
programming the quadruped in to actually
get the climbing action to take place
and then finally maybe you want all the
power you have individual motor control
as well and the reason why you might
want to do this is if you wanted to
program the actual gate of the quadruped
so right now the gate of this quadruped
is likely
meant as a very stable gate my guess is
this quadruped can actually run even
faster
it just might not be as stable it may
eventually trip and fall and my guess is
that's not something that they want to
actually ship out but you can probably
improve this gate further also the gate
is most likely hand coded by somebody on
that team whereas we could possibly use
some sort of a deep learning ai
algorithm on the raspberry pi or maybe a
more powerful board to control the gate
so
again if you're trying to get into that
really really deep deep control of the
quadruped this would be something you'd
be interested in to interface with the
serial protocol you have a ton of
options and that along with the
multi-tiered control at that serial
level is what makes this quadruped at
least for me a great introduction you
could go through the ai module and or
bluetooth the phone app that works out
of the box for example is using
bluetooth and i assume it actually is
communicating with this protocol over
bluetooth
unfortunately i couldn't figure out how
to interface with the ai module or the
bluetooth being an early review unit i
just i don't think they had the
documentation like fully ready the exco
team was responsive to questions but
being on the other side of the world
made communication take a while and i'm
not a patient man
my guess is if you could interact with
this protocol over bluetooth it would be
totally acceptable to do the whole body
or even single leg control
over bluetooth at least to some extent
unless you're trying to make the the
quad run or something like that maybe
but then if you really wanted to do
single motor control my guess is if
you're trying to do something like a
gate algorithm you really need that to
be on
like literally hardwired but either way
getting something hardwired is really no
big deal at all you can just swap out
the ai module for any other board that
you want i went with a raspberry pi just
because the form fits the size but
anything that can transmit and receive
cereal should work just fine here i
ended up just strapping the raspberry pi
to the top with an impact absorption
separation device
using an adjustable attachment mechanism
and now with this the raspberry pi has
wi-fi so i can either communicate with
it over wi-fi to issue live commands and
control the quadruped that way or i
could save the instructions to the
raspberry pi with a pi file or any other
file and then i can run them at boot or
again i can run them via ssh or both
so again algorithms that would be like
controlling gate should probably be on
the board you could you know start them
up via ssh but you probably want that
all happening on the board but if we
want to have maybe a camera and some
distance sensors or even like lidar or
something like that uh the higher level
ai stuff we just for navigation we
actually could communicate the you know
the sensor information over wi-fi or
bluetooth
and then use a more powerful machine to
run more complex algorithms so if you're
trying to do a high-level task like walk
around you don't really have to do that
on board you could communicate you could
even communicate with like a cloud
machine so a ton of options there so now
let's see an example of serial
communication with the x go mini and in
this case i'm going to be using python
and pi serial but you could use quite
literally anything to communicate
serially with this uh this quadruped
so um here i'm going to pull up the
documentation again and this is for that
protocol and again if i had to ask for
the protocol they might actually share
it when this actually gets shipped out
but if not i'll put a link in the
description so anybody can access this
if you end up getting the same one
here just as a quick note this is where
you can um
the ai module i believe was plugged in
here and essentially this is where my pi
goes so i'm using the trans uh transmit
receive and ground pin here and then i'm
actually using the 5 volt pin here to
power my raspberry pi and then here
we've got the bowed rate and everything
else that you could need so again you
just use this for the initial connection
and then finally we get to the
communication format so here we have the
prefix
and this is all in like hex notation so
and programming hex notation so you have
your prefix and then you'll have a byte
that is the length of the message then
you'll have the actual message
and then your checksum and then your
suffix gets appended so down here we can
see an example
of where is an example
i'll just try to find one yeah okay here
we go so this is your prefix this is
your um the length this is read or write
this is a write
this is the actual message this is your
checksum and then this is your suffix so
as you can see here i've gone ahead and
just pre written in prefix and suffix
so now back to the protocol
documentation we're going to scroll down
to the address table here and i think
probably the first place that you're
going to go is the whole unit control
mode and so everything's kind of
separated by color here so basically
everything of these colors is the whole
unit mode
so what we're going to i think start
with most obvious would just be to make
make it go forward so actually we'll end
up building pretty much the same command
that we saw above but this is just kind
of showing you um kind of how to break
that down
into an actual program that you might
write so you're not handwriting these
commands every single time
so
for example in this case we know we can
either read or write so we can read what
is the current or we can write what we
want it to actually be and so to do that
we're going to find that address and
then at that address what are we going
to do what we're going to try to write
this is the starting value which i think
is 128
should be like nothing stand still and
then it ranges every from everywhere
from 0 to
essentially 255 is what this ff notation
is
so
um
so yeah so what we can do is just maybe
make the robot go forward stop go back
stop and that could be it so so we'll
show that as an example so coming back
over uh to our code
we'll go ahead and come down and begin
our function so we'll start by defining
a function i'm going to call it whole x
for whole body movement along the x axis
so i am calling that the x-axis because
that is what the documentation how the
documentation referred to it is so x is
forward and back y is side to side z is
your up and down so whole x and then
essentially we just want to pass to this
speed so
the way that we'll
go from here is to first we'll specify
what is going to be the length of this
because essentially uh if you remember
those command like the order of command
it was uh prefix and then length so in
this case it's just going to be
[Music]
0x 09
so it's just 9 bytes long
then we're going to have read or write
and in this case we are going to write
so that was the
specified byte for writing uh the next
thing that we want is the actual command
that we're going to pass and in this
case
again going to the table it was uh at 30
for the table
for
where are you here
uh to address forward and backward
movement the default is uh 80 here and
what we want is to
or really it's 128 so 80 in hex notation
128
naturally so we're going to use 128 for
like that default speed
and um but as you can see it's a range
of this to this which is essentially a
range of 0 to 255. um
so what we're going to say is at the
address of
30 what do we want to do and in this
case we're going to pass whatever the
speed was that we passed to
the actual function itself so again this
will this will be something like zero
somewhere between 0 and 255 and uh 128
is
uh middle so like do nothing zero would
be full backwards 255 full speed ahead
so that's our command then we want to do
the checksum and again referencing our
documentation for checksum it is the
equivalent of whoops
it's basically going to be uh 255 minus
the sum of
the
uh length plus your message modulo 256.
so thanks daniel by the way so i i could
not figure out what the how the heck i
was supposed to write that so the
checksum in this case
boom is 255 minus the sum of the length
plus the row plus command so in our case
uh
the reader write and the command is part
of the
uh message basically so that's
how this is i suppose but
very difficult to read that um and then
finally we are going to just add this
all together so our the actual data that
we're going to send in is going to be
the prefix plus the length plus the read
or write plus the command plus the
checksum plus the
suffix
and then finally we're actually ready to
send that in so the send information is
going to be the bytes of data and later
you could just bytes up here but
whatever
and then finally we're going to serial
dot write
whatever we wanted to send
so
and the purpose of the checksum is just
purely
it
it's a way for the
receiving end to know is this what you
intended to actually send because again
one of the things that happens like if
the length is wrong or if maybe
something got timed out or maybe you
know something went wrong along the way
this is how you kind of know if if
something is awry
so we will go ahead and send that in and
that's basically all there is to it so
now we could just come down here and we
could um hold x
and we can go ahead and make it run
forward
uh we will time dot time dot sleep
for one second and then basically i'm
just gonna copy this paste paste paste
so we'll do uh 128 so it'll run forward
for a second it'll stop for a second it
will go backwards for a full second and
then once again it will stop for a
second
so now what we can do is we can save
that and i've been using filezilla
to transfer
yes
and now that is up on the
uh machine and
pulling it over we can execute that with
python 3. what did i call this
x go example dot pi let me
and he's gonna walk right off the box
one sec
and now now we can test it
and it worked
that's all for now in the next video
i'll try to do something a little more
advanced so stay tuned for that thanks
for watching and i'll see you all in the
next video
you